depuis le printemps dernier mais wayne
ne vient plus que quatre jours par
semaine à son bureau situé à trappes son
employeur l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines lui permet
d'effectuer une journée en télétravail
quand elle reste à son domicile pour
remplir ses missions ce sont 100 km de
trajet en voiture économiser beaucoup de
fatigue en moins du stress en moins lié
aux bouchons à la circulation
et puis du coup une amplitude de travail
élargie puisque voilà 2h à 2h30 30
transport en moins c'est sûr que c'est
autant de temps
de plus qu'assez sur le travail
aujourd'hui 87 agents de la collectivité
sont en télétravail il gagne en tout
près de 160 heures de trajet une mise en
place effective après une
expérimentation menée en 2018 en lien
avec les partenaires sociaux
ça permet aux agents de pouvoir
organiser leur vie un peu différemment
et tout le monde s'y retrouve on s'y
retrouve aussi sur le plan
environnemental
parce que là du coup on produit moins de
gaz toxiques
voilà au moins une voiture moins deux
mois d'utilisation de voitures et donc
par conséquent je pense que ça peut être
bénéfique bien sûr en tout cas bien
évidemment pour les agents à partir du
moment où le service public n'est pas
interrompue il ya aucune raison qu'une
chose ne se fasse pas saint quentin en
yvelines souhaite montrer l'exemple aux
autres collectivités en 2018 seulement à
0,1 pour cent des effectifs de la
fonction publique territoriale était en
télétravail